[Music]
[Music]
thanks banging here so this is gonna be
about some joint work with with Thomas
vidiq and it's in these archive papers
if you want to come up so let me just
get started by saying so this talk is
about a notion of verification and I
guess we already heard about one type of
verification this morning and this is
going to be a slightly different model
but to really like set the stage let me
talk about the classical world and tell
you about NP and and and interactive
proofs so you can think of so I guess we
probably all have heard of the class NP
which is to refresh your memory you know
it has all these problems which there
exists an efficient witness that
certifies that the answer is correct so
for instance any poly-time computation
is in NP because you can just give the
transcript of the computation and that's
your witness but there also many of
these interesting optimization problems
that line NP and you can think of the
class NP as sort of a game where you
know there's a prover who's trying to
convince you that the answer to the
problem is yes and then you are the
verifier and you want to be convinced of
the correct answer so you need to make
sure the prover is not cheating you so
so so the prover will send you some some
witness which is like a polynomial size
classical object and then and then you
check it and so the problem is in NP if
there's some algorithm the verifier can
execute where it'll accept you know
correct proofs and it'll reject wrong
proofs
so that's NP and then you could imagine
taking this this game and making it more
powerful by it by adding interaction
between the prover and the verifier what
I should also maybe clarify one thing
here so the prover here is is assumed to
be all-powerful right so so maybe I'm
like in room less talk in the morning or
whether the approvers are restricted to
be computationally bounded here the
prover can do anything it wants and only
the verifier is computationally bounded
and often I guess people refer to the
verifiers like King Arthur because he's
bounded in the provers is the wizard
Merlin so you could imagine changing
this model by adding interaction between
the prover and the verifier so the the
verifier might come up with a series of
challenges and send them to the prover
and get back responses and and and try
to decide whether the answer the problem
is yes or no that way and classically
it's sort of known that interaction
increases the power of these proof
systems so this is model IP where you
have polynomial in many rounds of
interactions say and then you can really
solve any problem in peace faced in ni
peace any problem that can be solved in
polynomial space and I guess we believe
that peace space is a bigger class than
NP so that's one thing you can do and
then you could imagine further
generalizing this model by saying
instead of just one proved earth at
interact with what if I have more than
one and I try to sort of play them
against each other so if one Coover
tries to lie to me maybe there lyle be
inconsistent with the law given by a
second prover as this is this model MIP
multi proved our interactive proofs so
here you have say two or more provers
that are not allowed to communicate to
each other and then you get to to send
them challenges and receive responses
and decide whether to accept or reject
so it turns out that MIP is is even more
powerful still so so mi p was shown by
by these authors to be equal to NX so
this is like non-deterministic
exponential times this is like the
exponentially scaled-up version of NP so
so really this multi prove our
interaction seems to add a lot of power
and another way you could view this
result well it's not exactly equivalent
it's take it took a fair amount of work
to get from from there to this one but
if you scale down the results you're
talking about a multi proved or
interacted protocol where the number of
bits you exchanges is only logarithmic
in the instant size so that's what I've
written log and bit messages here and
that turns out to be equal to NP so so
this is one formulation of what's on
this the PCP theorem so just to say what
this means is saying that there's this
NP problem it has a
witness that's polynomial a big and you
the verifier can somehow check it by
only exchanging logarithmically many
bits with these provers it's like you're
doing some spot check that can that can
always detect errors in this witness so
this is really you know this is a highly
non-trivial result and it's kind of
surprising so that's the the state of
the of affairs for classical proofs but
we don't necessarily believe that
classical proofs can exist for all the
problems were interested in in
particular this is a quantum computing
workshop so one problem we're very
interested in is is quantum computation
so V QP and it's not we have certainly
no reasons with the BCP is contained in
NP so there's may not be any efficient
classical proof of correctness for a
quantum computation but there exists a
quantum proof so this is the the notion
behind the class qma so the class QM a
is is is really just like NP except now
you're allowed a quantum proof and a
quantum verifier that can read the proof
and decide whether it's correct or not
so this contains bqp because you can use
this construction due to Fineman and
Kataya to encode a sort of transcript of
any quantum computation into a quantum
state and then you can check that state
by it by measuring its energy according
to a particular Hamiltonian this is the
history straight estate construction
that that we've heard about and then
also this class contains other problems
that are independently interesting at is
yes indeed right ok so this is kind of
trivial in the same way that P being
attained in NP is trivial but I mean
later when we talk about you know
putting qma in other classes that have a
classical verifier this will be more
interesting
okay so I guess the other point I wanted
to make is that that qma is contains
more than just bqp it also has this
independently interesting problem you
called the local Hamiltonian problem
which is sort of given a Hamiltonian
decide whether it's you know computed
its ground state energy up to some small
like polynomial a small precision and
this problem is is sort of believed to
capture the difficulty of many problems
in condensed matter physics so it's
independently industry interesting for
that reason so that's what quantum
proofs can do if you have a quantum
verifier to check them what if you add
interaction in the quantum world what
what changes so you could imagine taking
the single prover model IP and and
adding quantumness so they're the only
sensible way of doing this is you need
to allow for quantum messages and a
quantum verifier because if you if
either those things are classical then
you would just you know be trivially
equal to IP I believe but in terms of
even with you know adding the
quantumness in both the messages and the
verifier then your class is no more
powerful than IP so it was shown that
the Qi P is equal to P space what about
the multi prover model so now here there
are many things you could do so you know
there are many moving parts here and you
can imagine quantizing all of them the
model I'm going to consider here is
where you you give the provers quantum
power but you don't give quantumness to
the verifier so this is a class called
MIP star where the provers are now
they're still not allowed to communicate
to each other during the protocol but
they can share a quantum entanglement
that they've agreed upon in advance but
then during the protocol the verifier is
classical and it exchanges only
classical messages with these proofs and
so the first thing i want to point out
here is that it's not at all obvious
that this class I've defined should even
contain MIP because I'm granting the
provers more power which means it's
easier than for them to cheat and so the
protocols that were developed previously
may no longer be sound in this setting
but you know indeed it was possible to
show that
it you know you that they are sound or
modifications of them are sound so in
the scale down setting where I have log
bit messages this class contains NP and
ok so I guess these results showed it
for for for three provers and now we
know there's also four to prove errs
okay but that's just saying you can
reproduce these classical results can
you go further so I think the question
that's very interesting here is can you
use this class to check a quantum proof
it's not known whether tense herbal
entanglement if you are if you're
allowing infinite entanglement
equivalent to commuting measurements
yeah so which which of those versions of
myths are they should really just be two
different alexei classes actually for
the time being sure both versions of
star i believe it does i mean i'm sure
it applies to the tensor product model i
think yeah
um but but you don't have a bound on how
much fun it entanglement so there's
still no upper bound on the tensor
product version of MIPS term maybe this
is what you're about to say
and intensified finite point so so for
this notorious commuting Benjamin's
entangle with bottle it's still open
whether it's enjoy you guys suspect the
result extends when it hasn't so okay so
yeah it was a great question I guess for
the rest this talk at least you couldn't
just assume the tensor product model so
when I talk about MIPS star that's
that's what I mean
but and also maybe that raises an
important point so I said that these
provers a lot to share an entangled
state but I didn't specify any balance
on how much entanglement is allowed here
right so so it could be arbitrarily
large and that's sort of part of the
difficulty of dealing with this
complexity class comes from this so okay
but to get back to this question here so
I guess what I'm asking here is is
really in complexity terms is this this
MIPS star contained qma right because
qma is the class of quantum proofs and
this would be sort of qualitatively
interesting because the verifier here is
classical and you're only exchanging
classical messages with with the prover
so somehow you have to like command them
to do some quantum task for you without
ever holding a quantum object in your
hands so that's that's sort of the
challenge here and then also you'd be
showing that this class is you know
bigger than then then MIP
assuming that QM a is not equal to NP
which I guess is a safe assumption we
think so in this direction what could
you sort of conjecture might be true
well you might conjecture that if you
take the classical result so this is
what I showed two slides ago that that
MIP with with log size messages is equal
to NP and you just like stick a Q on
both sides that this might be true so
that if I take NP and convert it to Q MA
and I take mi p inverter to mi P star
that that this inclusion would hold I
don't want to conjecture an equality
here and so this is a conjecture this is
in a paper by Fitzsimmons and vidiq and
they called it the the the game's
quantum PCP conjecture or the
interactive proofs quantum PCP
conjecture this for the reason that that
it's sort of a generalization of this
thing which is the the piece one variant
of the PCP theorem in the classical
world
um
[Music]
right so this is the the target were
going to be aiming at for the rest of
the talk
[Music]
so why would you want to prove such a
thing so I guess I mentioned these
points earlier but maybe it's good to
reiterate them the first thing is that
if you showed this then this would tell
you something interesting about these
protocols with entanglement so this
would show that for instance if I give
you a specification if a protocol and
you want to compute the maximum success
probability over all strategies that
it's strictly harder to do this with
intent if you look at entangled
strategies than classical strategies
assuming you you allow assuming that qma
is is not equal to NP so that's sort of
interesting because I guess people have
cared about this this question of
computing the maximum success
probability in these protocols another
Twiddy under constant yeah so yeah I
should maybe clarify on this slide so
what so far I haven't talked about the
the completeness and soundness parameter
so these protocols and I I don't mention
them I intend them to be constants like
in the yes case you succeed with 2/3
probability in the no case you succeed
with it most one-third probability
so the second point I think is is quite
interesting which is that again on this
assumption that Kiyomi is not equal to
NP you're trying to show that this class
is this class MIP star is strictly more
powerful than MIP which means that
somehow you have to make use of the
additional resources you gave the
provers so the provers in particular
must share some sort of entanglement you
in the honest case where they're playing
according to your the strategy you want
them to use in your protocol and this is
kind of interesting because in other
settings where you look at verification
of quantum computation you know you
could you design protocols that maybe
could be passed like if the Coover were
exponentially powerful and had an
exponentially big classical description
of the state that it wanted to simulate
you could just you know compute all the
quantities you asked it to compute and
and and and pass the test but here you
know even that's not sufficient like
even if the prover is arbitrarily
powerful as a classical being if it
doesn't have this the shared
entanglement it shouldn't be able to to
pass your protocol so that's as
qualitatively interesting and sort of
different from the behavior you see in
the classical world and then finally
this this point about the QP being
contained in QM a is now now might lead
to something non-trivial because then
you would have a delegated computation
scheme perhaps where the the verifier or
like the client remains classical for
vqp don't you already have an MEP store
protocol from this re video as mentioned
before oh yes okay that's going to be on
the next slide so I'll tell you how we
want to improve on that
okay so um it's like maybe a couple
slides from here so I will mention it
so um I guess just to clarify what the
task is that we were doing so I thought
I wanted to design an MIP start protocol
for 40 OMA so that means I should take
you know some qma problems so take this
local Hamiltonian problem that I
mentioned earlier and I just I should
design a protocol for that say so
instances of this problem are described
by Hamiltonians right and and the answer
is yes if the minimum energy of this
Hamiltonian is below some threshold a
and it's no if it's above some threshold
B so I want to come with a way to map a
Hamiltonian to a protocol in such a way
that if the energy is below the
threshold then the probability of
success in my protocol is is high and if
it's above the threshold and the
probability of success should be low and
then as I mentioned you need to somehow
use entanglement to do this but also not
now that you're allowing entanglement
you need to like prevent the
entanglement from being used to cheat
you and so here you you have to keep in
mind that you you don't know what the
like the size of the entangled state is
the provers are sharing it so you just
somehow show that for whatever protocol
you come up with you know even at the
provers share an enormous Liebig
entangled state they can't fool you
using that in some way
so how would you go about doing this
so really the the key idea here that
that that's used in all the works in
this direction is is this phenomenon
called self testing that was I guess
discovered almost in the physics
literature so it's gonna tie into this
thing I said about how you to design a
protocol that certifies entanglement so
it turns out that there exists games or
interactive proof protocols where they
had this very strong sort of rigidity
property that in order to succeed with
close to the optimal success probability
you must use not just entanglement but
some particular fixed entangled state
and so this is just defining what the
the primitive is in the next slide I'll
show you an example of this game but
like you'd say that that a protocol is a
self test for some states I if you know
if you you know you can succeed with
high probability if you use that state
and if you succeed with close to the
optimal probability you must the shared
state between the provers must be close
to sy and so it's a little bit careful
when you define what it means to be
close to sy because each prover could
apply a local unitary rotation to you
know there are half of sy and then you'd
never be able to tell right but so what
this means is that sort of up to this
freedom of local unit Ares and local
isometry is the shared state must be
close to sy
so does this notion sort of make sense
there is there any questions at this
point
so the physics literature this comes out
of Bell inequalities in favor of one
particular concept because I have it all
even showing that indeed so this is like
it's not known whether itself just
exists for any side it is for some
particular size we were able to
construct yeah yeah favorable sides
so I guess the the example um that's
known is this famous CH SH game so first
I'll just briefly remind you some
properties of this game it's it's so
this is really like a mallet
simplification of bells original Bell
inequality but you can think of it as
like an interactive protocol where
there's a verifier that exchanges you
know there's one round of interaction
the verifier sends one bit to each of
two quantum provers and it receives back
a single bit and and sort of what was
shown by by by béla was that if the the
to quantum prover share this EPR state
so so like a single you know e bit of
entanglement then they can succeed in
this protocol with higher probability
than any classical strategy could so
that's what Bell showed are now the self
testing property which holds for this
game is actually the following so I said
that the well maybe I didn't say this
but it's true that the optimal success
probability in this game is something
like 85% which is achieved with this EPR
state and it turns out that if you
succeed with probability like 85% minus
Delta then the state you share has to be
close to this EPR state up to error
square root Delta up to two local
isometry so this is a protocol that you
can use to test that you know there's
one bit of entanglement between the two
pores and you might be annoyed by the
85% but you can also design a test with
perfect completeness with with a
different game called the Magic Square
game but oh I'll refer to CH SH just for
simplicity in the rest of the talk
okay so I guess they've introduced this
notion of self testing but only for a
very simple state right at the the
single EPR state and what I really
wanted to do was design a protocol for a
QM a complete problem so this suggests a
sort of strategy which is I want us a
protocol that's a self test but not for
the EPR state but rather for the witness
state of my QM a problem so if I take
local Hamiltonian I want design a self
test for states of low energy according
to my Hamiltonian and so this is indeed
the idea that was I guess
implicit in this is worked by by rycart
Unger and masrani so they were able to
show by sort of applying many copies of
the CH SH test that there is indeed an
MIP start protocol for 4q MA
where the number of bits of
communication between the verifier and
the provers is polynomial in the
instance size because you have to sort
of do polynomial in many repetitions of
this CH SH test and and apply some some
statistical analysis to the outcomes and
so on I guess it depends what you mean I
don't know why it's called a salt test I
guess the idea is that a state is
certifying itself only through
measurements on it but yeah
this is an obscure term maybe someone
else knows the history
okay so then I guess there was
subsequent work in this direction so
this protocol was was an MIP stars I
defined it with like this constant
completeness soundness gap now it turns
out that sort of if you relax that
requirement and you you allow the the
gap to be much smaller so in the yes
case I succeed with some probability see
and in the no case I succeed probably
most see - an inverse polynomial then so
if it students in vidiq discovered this
protocol with Quantum messages but but
only like log sized messages that that
achieved that could solve problems in
qma and you can think about this is sort
of instead of so this ruv thing applied
sort of something to check every qubit
in the state that they wanted to
characterize and now here instead of
checking every qubit because you're
you're not requiring this disk out to be
so big you can just check a few qubits
messages to the provers yes back and
forth
with rumors completeness one sound this
one hand that's correct yeah and just
simply by ignoring all but one Hoover
isn't that the same as IP were like ah I
see
yes so I guess really the the
application they wanted this for was was
then I could show that any MIP star
protocol with Quantum messages could
could actually be done with classical
messages like so that's something that
does not follow from from known
complexity results but like in
particular one on the left you could put
you can even put cumin its what follows
from right yes that's correct so that
that also held in their case for bqp I
guess it's another between yes indeed
yeah so this is this is not this
statement does not capture the all the
good qualities the result yeah just to
understand sitting mole design I mean
that the two approvers just share like a
bunch of EPR pairs and one of the most
immense size this how the way to think
about it yes so this actually differs in
the different protocols so I in this
protocol I think it's something like
that so they they hold a bunch of EPR
pairs and then in the course of the
protocol they will prepare sigh by like
you know their EP are pairs with them
like some resource state and they'll
prepare some version of sigh in these
later protocols there's a different way
of doing it where you sort of encode
sigh with an error correcting code and
distribute that amongst approvers which
I would have if I have time at the end
I'll I'll show you how that's done it
but if you're not BGP that just
preparing side by yourself might be hard
right and not indeed
it needs to be given in something in
some form yes yeah so but in all these
yes when all these protocols if you're
given a copy of the ground state then
you can prepare whatever state you need
to do the protocol yeah certainly for
for the ones after ruv I think that's
also true for the RTP protocol
this is for quantum messages and then
this subsequent work by by Jen Feng G
showed you could also do sort of the
same thing with classical messages
so maybe it's best to compare these two
things so we started out by saying you
and there's this protocol for qma with
polynomial size messages but it has the
completeness soundness gap you'd expect
then here's another protocol where you
have only log size messages but the gap
is small so you need to repeat the
protocol many times to really you know
be confident of the answer and what we
want to do is is is like get this but
with this gap so the completeness
soundness gap should be it should be a
constant with only log size messages and
I haven't explained how exactly but
somehow all these things are based on
tests for EPR pairs and in order to
improve this gap really what's needed is
a test for many EPR pairs where the the
Campinas on this gap of the test does
not depend badly on the number of EPR
pairs are testing a bit more about how
you connect the test of the two tests of
the general histories daggered sure so I
um I can maybe draw a diagram here I
think I have a or actually I let me skip
ahead to this slide that does this just
because it has a
right so it's gonna be something like so
in general this history state what we're
gonna do to it is
encode it with some error correcting
code so like say this this coding codes
every qubit into K qubits right so then
there'll be K provers and we'll
distribute it amongst the the K provers
and then you can sort of lift a test for
EPR pairs into a test for code States by
sort of using the fact that if you
partition this into like you know one
prover and the other six and you think
of these so here I guess I've drawn
seven but if you purchase this into like
one prove are and the rest the state
across that cut looks like an EPR state
and then you can apply the EPR test to
every cut and and then by doing that
you've certified that the test that the
state is encoded the way you want it to
be and then once you have an encoded
state you can then command the provers
to do things like like measure logical
operators and that's how you extract the
energy
so he
right so I guess if the sort of four
experts if you didn't follow that's okay
the main point is that somehow there's
these known strategies for lifting a
test or EPR pairs into a test for AK you
may witness state and really it seems
like the the technical challenge was to
design a good test from any EPR purse so
I guess that brings me to sort of the
the main result is that yes this is
indeed possible so we're able to design
a to prove ER protocol where you can
test that the provers share and EPR
pairs using only log n bit questions and
answers and the completeness and
soundness errors don't depend on on n so
it's just they just depend on the error
to which you want to test the state so
if I want to test that the state is
epsilon close to any PR pairs the
soundness is is like 1 minus some
polynomial and epsilon independent of N
and then if you take this this tester
EPR pairs and you plug it into this
framework that I'm not describing you
can turn it into a protocol for testing
these ground states as well so you can
get a so this is all tied to phrase in
this sort of strange way because there's
there's like a random noise reduction
going on in here but you can at least
show that it's QM a hard to estimate
whether the success probability in in a
given MIP star protocol is greater than
2/3 or less than one thirds so this is
sort of close to this statement that I
said was our goal which is you know just
putting QM a directly in this class by
giving a protocol for it
od is just some universal constant that
i haven't computed
so this is the statement of this result
make sense okay yes so the the
randomized reduction is something like
given a QM a problem so you're given a
Hamiltonian you can construct a protocol
out of it but the the mapping from the
Hamiltonian to the protocol is
randomized so it's like you apply some
some bpp computation to the description
of the of the Hamiltonian and you get
out a protocol like what exactly do you
mean by test it up to an error epsilon
oh I just mean that like if you succeed
with probability greater than maybe it's
better to invert this if you can see is
probably greater than 1 minus Delta then
you know that the state that's shared by
the the provers is like Delta to the 1
over D close in this metric I talked
about earlier to the NE PR state
like if you want to for instance like
your end goal is probably going to have
epsilon be some small constant and in
that case this will also be some
constant
okay so the protocol that we actually
design here is a little bit complicated
and I'm going to tell you about a
simpler protocol that achieves sort of
it doesn't achieve quite the so it's
less efficient in terms of communication
so it involves sending more bits between
the the prover and the verifier but a
lot of the ideas used in analyzing this
protocol are similar to the the more
efficient one and so this is what we
called the the poly braiding test for
four reasons it'll maybe become clear
when I talk about the actual test let me
just tell you what the the parameters
are so it's basically the same sort of
thing is on the previous slide except
instead of log n bit questions it's it's
it's n bit questions and so I think when
we were coming up with this result it's
sort of like there were two parameters
that we cared about right it's the
efficiency in terms of the number of
bits communicated and also this the
soundness error and it seemed like the I
guess the pathway we followed this first
to like achieve this good soundness
error at the cost of poor communication
efficiency and then improve on the
communication and so why is it called
the poly Brading test well it involves
asking the involves for testing that the
provers are applying measurements from
the polygroup on their state and it
involves like checking and rigor of some
some highly non-local measurements so
I'm going to show you what the
measurements are in in a second so
so let me remind you first of a few
facts about poly matrices so the poly
matrices you know they all so so I'm
only going to talk about X and Z in this
talk I'm not going to mention the Y so
these are two matrices that act on say a
single qubit so they're two by two
matrices it's square to identity and
they anti commute so so X Z is equal to
minus Z X so that's like the the single
qubit pallies and I'm gonna introduce
this notation for for tensor products of
these so I'll say that like an N cubed
poly X of a is is going to be the tensor
product so so a here is going to be a
binary string and X of a will be the
tensor product that consists of poly X
acting on all the locations where a is a
1 and identity acting in all the
locations where a is a 0 and similarly
for Z so now these things satisfy you
can just like this is almost just
notation so so they satisfy some
relations so if I take the product of
two x's sort of you know if on any
particular location if I have two x's
they'll cancel out and give me identity
sets and if I only have one X I'll I'll
sort of an X so that can be captured by
saying that that X of a times X of B is
is X of a plus B where this addition is
mod 2 and then likewise for the Z so
this is just like lifting these 2
relations to this many qubit notation
and then if I try to commute two of them
past each other I'll get a minus 1 for
every location in which there's both an
X and a Z so that's saying that X of a
times EB is is Z of B times X of a times
this phase which is minus 1/2 the inner
product between them so these are like
some algebraic relations that that
characterize what the Polly's do and
then there's another nice fact about
these pal of the operators is that they
can characterize the EPR state so if I
have some state with the property that
say it's a bipartite state on two qubits
and it's preserved by X tensor X or I
guess two n qubits and it's preserved by
Z tends to Z for
for all these choices of A's and B's
then the state must be the NEP our state
so this is just if you're familiar with
the stabilizer formalism this is just
saying that that these operators are
like the stabilizer group of the EPR
state so so now that I've introduced
these facts let me tell you how we use
them in our test so remember our end
goal was to check that the provers share
these EPR pairs and so we're going to
use that last fact to do this by asking
to measure all of those stabilizers you
know this X of a tensor X of a and Z of
B tends to Z of B so in order to do that
we to first check that they're actually
measuring a poly operator on some qubits
and that we do by checking the relations
I wrote out on the previous page so the
first relation was that when you take
the product of two x's you get another X
I'm going to check that as follows we're
going to ask one prover to measure both
X of a and X of B for some a and B on
their half of the state and then I'm
going to ask the second prover to
measure X of a plus B and then some X of
C for some randomly chosen C and and the
purpose of the X of C is just to confuse
them so they don't know you know what
which of these things is supposed to be
X of a plus B so to make the
distributions of queries look equal and
then we just check so first of all this
is a measurement that they can do
because the you know all the different
X's commute with each other so you can
simultaneously measure them and then we
just check that this relation holds so
that the outcomes that I get here and if
I take their product should be equal to
the outcome that was reported for X of a
plus B so if you're familiar with the
classical literature this is really
identical to a classical test for for
linearity of boolean functions and we're
just applying it to the measurement
outcomes of these X operators now the
second relation I wrote on on the
previous slide was the same thing for
Z's and so I can do the same test for
Z's I just asked the provers measure Z
in this way and tell me the outcome and
I checked that the products are correct
and the third relation was this phase
relation right so I said that that X of
a and Z would be either commute or
depending on this inner product so the
way I'm going to check that is is just
use the the CH SH game which I mentioned
a while back so what I'll do is I'll
just pick an A and a B such that X of a
and ZEB are supposed to anti commute and
then sort of the thing is that when they
anti commute
they really behave like operators on the
single qubit so I can somehow just ask
them to play the CH SH game but using
these two operators instead of whatever
single qubit operators they'd have use
in the CH SH game and it turns out you
can show that if you succeed in this
game the the operators you you use have
to be close to anti commuting so that's
the test it verifies that relation okay
and then finally I've checked all these
relations that I said that the Polly's
have to satisfy I need to finally check
that the this last thing that the state
is is stabilized by those pallies so the
way I do that is I just ask the the
provers you know ask both the first and
the second paper to measure the same
thing so they dad they're both measure
some acts of a or some Z if B and I just
checked they get the same outcome
so this implements this this last
equation I wrote and then this is
supposed to tell me that the approvers
are indeed sharing an EPR state okay so
these are like the four components of
the test their question ch ch SH eres
test
to bellperre yes actually entangled
- quad rather
U+ era and it has the properties that
has several properties one is the clean
this is a hundred percent for the tats
and another is that it just directly
uses multiple operators rather rather
than super positions like that
ah so I'm wondering whether a parent's
version of your idea so indeed we
actually do use that so I'm only using
CHS aids for the slide because it's too
complicated to write the actual
operators that are used in this like
Paris Magic Square game but like indeed
we actually use the III guess yeah I
think they call it the magic well it's
like it's based on the magic square in
some sense so if I'm going in the right
thing bourbon didn't even write qubit
with you
I thought of the era's is it's being
defined in sort of additive Oh
determines which right which is which is
more employable why it's valuable but
okay you you actually do it that way
instead interaction in your papers so
funny okay
right so that's yeah that's for instance
necessary to get because I claim perfect
completeness for my tests a few slides
ago and you need it to achieve that
because as you pointed out that achieves
perfect completeness for a CH SH does
not but for the purposes of the slide I
mean you can just think of this as any
sort of test that certifies a single
qubit or maybe like two qubits of
entanglement it's it's really all by
using it is to check this phase relation
between two Poly's and and any game that
does that would be fine
so okay so these are the the four
components of the test and now I have to
tell you why this works I just told you
I got claimed that you know these are
some relations that the poly operators
satisfy and then so therefore you should
and I'm I said these are like checking
these relations but it's not clear that
you couldn't satisfy this test in some
other way so so why is this test even
work so let me give you a very
high-level sketch of the proof so the
first thing that I have to say is so I
guess on the previous slide it was clear
that if I you know really perform the
measurements that I was supposed to do I
will succeed in all the tests with
probability one now I have to work so
from the converse Samer I know that I
succeeded in the test with probability
say one minus epsilon and not to do some
consequence about the measurement
operators that were used so the first
thing I can say it is um I mean take
some algebra to show this is that if you
have some operators which I'm labeling X
of a and Z of B but i'm not claiming
that their pal is yet they're just some
things that have been claimed to be pal
the operators but if they succeed in the
tests on the previous slide they must
satisfy those relations on the shared
state up to some epsilon where epsilon
here is is related to your success
probability in the game
oh is that step one now the second step
is sort of the magic step which is that
I have a bunch of operators that that
look like Polly's up to some Epsilon and
not have to use this rigidity property
of the polygroup so it turns out that if
you have these X of a and Z of these you
can round them to another set of
operators which I'm writing curly X and
curly Z that exactly satisfy these
relations so you'll not say that yet
so and then I said with with error
independent of n so that means that I'll
take you know this X and I'll say there
exists a curly X that some Delta away
from X where Delta depends only an
epsilon not an N such that these curly
X's and curly Z's now obey all these
equations exactly and they're still
close to the to the original axis so so
this second step is really what's
characterizing the strategy used by by
the provers it's saying that in order to
succeed
in this game they had to use
measurements that were close to some set
of things that behaves like the PAL the
operators and this is I guess appeared
in more general setting so this is sort
of you can understand this classical
linearity test that I mentioned earlier
as showing the same statement over the
group Z 2 to the N so and I guess this
is actually now known for any finite
group so this is shown by by Gower's and
hitomi that you have any set of matrices
that sort of approximately satisfy the
multiplication relations of the group
then there's a way to round them to to
another set that that exactly satisfies
those relations so it's an exact
representation of the group and then the
final step is that the polygroup sort of
we understand the the representations of
it so really like there's only one non
trivial representation again ignoring
issues of like what to do with the Y and
whether to use plus I or minus I and so
on but there's sort of a unique
irreducible representation that that
obeys this this phase relation and so
when I put this
together this implies that these things
that were claimed to be Polly X's and
policies really are close to Polly axis
and policies then finally from the
fourth part of the test which is this
consistency thing I can I can say well
now I know that the state is close to
being stabilized by by honest Polly spin
matrices and therefore it's close to the
EPR state
maybe I'll just say it very helpful
what's going on again so we wanted to
test the state the way we did it is in
like in a two-step procedure we first
tested a number of measurement operators
that the provers was supposed to act
with and we asked you know we checked
that they satisfied some algebraic
relations and then using that we
characterized the operators and then
from characterizing the operators we can
characterize the state they act on
okay so that's the analysis of this test
and so the analysis the more efficient
test I presented earlier is sort of
similar except you need to instead of
using all the power of the operators
there's a special subset that we have to
find that that comes out of a classical
error correcting code but I don't think
I have time to say anything about that
so I guess I'll conclude by saying a
little bit about applications of this
test for EPR pairs and and also like
maybe some open questions so I'll start
by saying first if you just take so I
mentioned that that bqp is contained in
Q MA and so if you just take this idea
and and and implement it in the most
straightforward way so you take our
protocol for Q ma you can also get a
delegated computation scheme for bqp
that has sort of the following property
so it's like a it'll have a large number
of provers so it'll have it turns out
seven provers but the verifier is
classical and it only needs to exchange
classical messages with these provers
and it can be confident the answer to
any bqp computation and furthermore the
provers are efficient they only need the
power of D Q P because they only need to
prepare this history state for the BGP
computation they're trying to certify so
this result that we showed is in sort of
a model called the post hoc model where
the provers first learned the circuit
they're supposed to delegate and then
they allow it to get together and
collude and design their strategy and
and then you separate them and and you
run the protocol and that's needed for
them to prepare this history state but
later work by several people who are
here so I guess Khalid Angelo Grillo
Jeffery and and and and Vinick we're
able to use our tests in a sort of
better way to obtain sort of almost
optimal delegation protocols so you can
delegate vqp and you can delegate a
circuit that contains say M gates using
resources like bits of computation and
and and rounds and so on that that's key
with almost linearly in em
so that's one application and the other
application I mentioned earlier was was
showing QM a hardness of this class MIP
star and so I won't say it again but
maybe I'll just review how did we go
from EPR pairs to this so basically what
we do is we want to actually test this
this QM a witness state and we do that
by encoding the cue may what in a state
using an error correcting code so this
idea is by the way do two Fitzsimmons
and vidiq so the code is just like a
single qubit code so there's for
instance codes that encode one qubit
into seven physical qubits so you could
take such a code and then we set the
number of provers to be equal to the
number of qubits in this code so if I
work the seven qubit code I'll now have
seven provers and I'll distribute for
each qubit in this witness state sigh
I'll encode it into seven cubits and
distribute one of them to each of the
seven provers and then one can apply so
these lifted versions of this EPR test
to check that the seven provers are
sharing a valid code state and then also
to command them to perform Palelei
measurements and then sort of poly
measurements are sufficient for checking
the energy of the encoded state and then
that's what you do to verify that this
this witness is a valid witness for a QM
a problem
so putting it all together it would be
you know the overall protocol for qma
would be something like with half
probability you you check that the
shared state is a valid code state by
doing this EP our test on some partition
of the provers and with half probability
you ask all of them to implement some
logical measurement of the energy
okay so I'm going to conclude by
mentioning some interesting open
problems in this area so one thing that
I think is very interesting is that so I
guess now we sort of know that MIP stars
is more powerful than MIP but but
there's no upper bound on on MIP star so
this is related to the issue that's been
mentioned of how there's no upper bound
on on how much entanglement the provers
could have to use and so one thing you
might ask for is protocols that require
the provers to share you know ever
increasing amounts of entanglement and
and maybe you get stronger lower bounds
in MIP star this way and indeed in the
regime where the completeness soundness
gap is very small we know that this
phenomenon occurs so there are these
results of of gen Feng G and then this
follow-up work that came out recently
that that shows sort of by some sort of
compression procedure where you take a
protocol and you compress it and then
you scale up again and you compress it
again that you can get like much
stronger lower bounds as you shrink the
completeness soundness gap and so I
think a very interesting question is can
we use any of the tests that I described
here to achieve you know some of the
lower bounds without shrinking the
completeness soundness gap as much and
it turns out that if you could improve
these compression results by even a
little bit then you might be able to
show okay so you would be able to show
that MIP star is undecidable which would
be I think quite interesting another set
of applications you could consider is
you know shared EPR powers are very
useful for cryptographic tasks like
quantum key distribution and there's
also like applications to delegated
computation that I mentioned but is
there more we could extract from from
our results something I want to think
about then finally this is a point maybe
for for experts here so I mentioned that
the conjecture that is working towards
is this quantum games PCP there's
another thing that's been called the
quantum PCP I guess is actually older in
the literature and this is a
generalization of a different
formulation of the classical PCP theorem
so there's other conjectures about
whether it's still qma hard to estimate
the energy of a local Hamiltonian up to
a constant rather than two and
best polynomial and so it was sort of
not known whether these two things were
related in any way and one consequence
of our work is an implication from this
other quantum PCP to the the game's
quantum PCP and I think it'll be
interesting to go the other way so this
would be sort of like classically
there's a nice connection between
constraint satisfaction problems and
these interactive proof protocols and
this would be developing the quantum
analog of that so how far can we go in
in both directions and finally the the
protocols I presented are all totally
unrealistic in the real world and in the
sense that they demand that unrealistic
in a world without fault-tolerant
quantum computation so they demand that
the provers should apply some some
highly non-local measurement like say
measuring apollyon on n qubits and they
should do this very precisely so we
don't tolerate you know even a small
constant error per cubic would be enough
to to make the provers fail in our tests
so it would be interesting to see what
guarantees we can get on a test that
could be in that a near-term quantum
device could succeed at and probably you
wouldn't be able to get something as
strong as what we have but it would
still be I think interesting because it
might be implementable in the near
future there may be some more
speculative questions so there's a
connection between this cross MIP star
and a conjecture and operator algebra is
called cons and vetti and conjecture so
in particular if collins and budding
conjecture is true some pliers that the
to prove our version of MIP star is is
decidable so if you showed
undecidability for to prove ersten you
would have disproved cons embedding
conjecture which it's maybe not such an
unreasonable thing because at least one
operator algebra says has said that that
he thinks it's false another interesting
question I think that's sort of related
to this connection between protocols and
constraint satisfaction problems is
coming with more complete problems for
qma so right now when we think about the
classic you may we really have to think
only about local Hamiltonian like we
don't really have I mean that there's
some other problems but
but they're not as many as in the
classical world they're like you know
there's a whole variety of np-complete
problems and we have techniques for from
manipulating them that are very useful
and finally there's this notion of self
testing that I mentioned we applied it
only to this very as Greg said favorable
state the EPR state and it's a very
interesting question to see what other
states you could test and in particular
can you test like not just states of
qubits but like these continuous
variable states that that I guess
experimentalists are actually preparing
the lab and finally in the analysis of
the test I mentioned that we use some
properties of approximate
representations of groups and you can
think about our more efficient tests as
sort of a sparse test for the polygroup
for representations of polygroup and
that we're asking the provers to to to
certify that their measurement operators
satisfy some small subset of relations
of the poly operators and that's
sufficient to conclude that there's an
entire representation of the palaver
group in their hilbert space and i think
will be interesting to see what other
groups you could do this for like is
there a general notion of group
representation testing where you only
check a small subset of the relations
that's all I had so thanks for listening
[Applause]
I mean certain question but have some so
with for example is there hope to do
self testing for found in ten states ah
I'm not sure I don't know how the bound
like the fact that hangman is bound will
make it harder to do the self-test like
I guess the the thing is that we've been
really focused on like the EPR stayed in
particular or at least when I thought
about this so I I don't really have a
good intuition even for like you know
non EPR states whether you could test
them like even if they're they're not
bound
wait further I guess I have a comment
under questions
the comment is if the cousin have any
conjecture is false and since we don't
go but it is true I would really
recommend giving these two different
flavors and myths are different names
it's just too confusing and in fact
there is a paper in the literature that
just states district Ursa and I asked
the author's about that and they said
well that's assuming the conjecture
that's assuming the cun betting the
direction it's I I think I think you
just have to have two different names
for these classes for the time being
maybe forever
but then the other comment I have the
question I have is when you say that you
you're pure speculation
you could disprove the cut the betting
conjecture is that using one of these
representations methods
I guess not directly so the path that I
was referring to is sort of using these
compression results and so the way they
work is it's sort of like applying a
history state construction to an MIP
start protocol it's like you you start
with an MIP start protocol and you want
to compress it bye-bye
so you compress it in the sense of
reducing the message length and that's
done by you you create a new protocol
where the new provers are supposed to
share some sort of history state of the
original MIPS tower protocol and then
the new verifier checks that this
history state is correct and then the
idea is that you would be able to
recursively apply this compression by
like you compress and then you scale up
the protocol and you can press it again
and then you could get stronger lower
bounds that's it
this oscillating compression thing has
group theory has a group theory engine
inside using something like multi-phase
well I think that there is sort of group
theory in the test for the for the state
like so that test for this history state
of the MIPS tower protocol is going to
be based on these tests for for
Hamiltonians are similar to them in some
way and it will involve you know asking
the provers to measure Poly's and
certifying that they're correct and i
think i would say that the only way we
know of like testing these pallies goes
through a group representation like this
representation in framework of the
policy implicitly but what concerns me
there is either I'm not completely sure
whether it's a special case of the ton
conjecture or and I have a close analog
for groups which is detected all all
finally generative roots are one indeed
all groups are hyper so called hyper
linear and that is part related to this
notorious thing and even stronger
conjecture is that all groups are so
thick and people are having the group
theorists are having tremendous
difficulty finding a counter example
even of that so
you know you'd have if you want to be
skeptical about pretend conjecture in
this group's hieratic setting there's an
even stronger conjecture that people
feel that some people feel like being
skeptical but but then but then it's
been extremely difficult to find
conjectures even to that color examples
even for that thing so so it it would be
let's say dramatic if quality
information gave you new tools for this
group Theory group theory problems thank
first time to think okay well maybe
variomatic
there's no let's say I think I that
[Applause]